everybody
chocolate chip
[Music]
thank you
proven this is the Reuben report it's
March 22nd in the year 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
if you want to join us for the post game
show chat with us during the show get
information and images and video to me
and the team you can do that by joining
us at Ruben report.locals.com and uh
we're going hardcore race horse not
racist race horse politics today
although I'm sure we can figure out a
way to sprinkle some racism and this is
you know the culture wars of America uh
yeah it's get intense people uh the
fighting has begun on the Republican
side what I'm really really going to try
to do over the next year until the next
election year and a half whatever it is
is I'm gonna really do my best not to be
adding fuel constantly to every little
every little bit of bickering and
nonsensical argument and do exactly you
know the thing that the media does they
take little things they make them big
things then we have big things and they
make them small things I'm really going
to try not to do that but there is some
jockeying going on right now and because
we're in this sort of uh I would say
kind of undefined space where the guy
who's presumably the leader of the thing
DeSantis hasn't announced you have the
other I suppose in his eyes presumed
leader and in many other people's eyes
presume leader as well Trump kind of
going after him I think there's been a
real energy shift this whole Insanity
out of New York with the D.A who
apparently is going to arrest Trump
although yesterday was Tuesday and there
were no arrests there's just like a lot
of energy that is Shifting right now and
I want to just dive into the pros and
cons of everybody and that will be to
the backdrop of what I did for the first
hour that I woke this morning I had my
coffee I fed the kids and then I did an
hour and a half podcast with Vivek
ramaswami now Vivek obviously has jumped
in he is run for president on the
Republican side he is launching a
podcast I'm the first guest and we we
set an intention
before we started we only chatted for a
minute or two uh before the camera
started rolling but Our intention was
that we would get into all of our
disagreements on all of the stuff and
talk about what I thought were his
strengths and weaknesses what I thought
were desantis's strength strengths and
weaknesses trumps Etc et cetera so it
was really good I think it's going to be
out on Monday but I think it kind of wet
the whistle for today's show uh so why
don't we get right to it how about that
but before we do let's talk about Birch
gold real quick uh you know you can buy
gold and get a free safe to store it in
that's right on qualifying purchases
from Birch gold group now through March
31st they'll ship a free safe directly
to your door visit birchgold.com Dave to
get your free info kit on gold and claim
your eligibility for your free safe
here's the deal the feds keep raising
rates because it's the only two tool
they have to keep inflation under
control that ain't working hint uh you
can't spend your way out of inflation
guys you've seen the market or you've
seen the impact on the stock market
you've seen the impact on your savings
hedge inflation by owning gold whether
physical gold and silver in your safe or
through an IRA and precious metals where
you can hold real gold and silver in a
tax sheltered retirement account Birch
gold has an A plus better rate a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
and thousands of satisfied customers
visit birchgold.com Dave for your free
info kit on gold and to claim
eligibility for your free home safe by
March March 31st on qualifying purchases
again visit birchgold.com Dave and now
back to me all right
here's the situation people there's a
presidential election coming there's
always a presidential election coming it
never stops we're always in an election
cycle and people want to be president to
rule the world that's what it's all
about uh the guy that everyone seems to
be focused on mostly is Ron DeSantis
right now now ironically Ron DeSantis
has not announced as you know but even
in the last couple days as this whole
brouhaha has broken out over Trump and
this possible arrest by the soros-backed
Lefty Progressive D.A of New York City
most of the Trump energy was spent on
attacking DeSantis for not defending
Trump enough and I think that's a real
shift that tells you that the energy has
moved so that when Trump is getting
attacked his inclination wasn't to
attack that way it was attack DeSantis
that is something worth noting because
something is afoot Governor DeSantis sat
down with Piers Morgan at the governor's
mansion in Tallahassee yesterday we're
going to show you a couple Clips here
but Piers did not hold back and he went
right at it Hey Ron can you beat
orangeman
I think you could beat bud I think so
so you're running them no I didn't say
that I just said I think I could I mean
I think that that's I mean if you look
at Florida it would be harder to be
Biden or Donald Trump workout
I don't know
the question obviously there was can you
beat Biden but really what it is is can
you beat Trump because that's what you
got to do to beat Biden so look the
Samantha says I can do it we don't know
if this antis is running it seems like
it's going in that direction but one of
the things that's happening as I've been
saying is that the attacks if you look
at Trump's troop Social account because
he's he's technically back on Twitter
but has not been tweeting there's some
questions as to what's going on there uh
it sounds like there's probably a lot of
legal reasons and a lot of money tied up
in truth that is forcing him to fully
stay there not go back on Twitter he may
have his own calculations and I don't
know what's going on there fully uh but
if you look at Trump's truth Social
account it's mostly attacking DeSantis
so you got to think all right here's the
guy who he thinks is the real threat at
the moment Piers asked Governor DeSantis
if uh the nicknames are getting them
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it Ron
Ronda sanctimonious or meatball rock
well I can't even he went off meatball
wrong I can't uh I don't know how to
spell the sanctimonious I don't really
know what it means but I you know I kind
of like it's long it's got a lot of
valve I mean so we'll go with that
that's fine you know you can call me you
can call me whatever you want I mean
just as long as you you know also call
me a winner because that's what we've
been able to do in Florida has put a lot
of points on the board and and really
take the state to the next level
I think that's the right response right
like you don't have to get upset about
the nicknames I don't think they're
quite working you know the fact that
Trump apparently was work shopping them
that he brought like a whole bunch of
people together are we going to call
them meatball Ron or Ron to
sanctimonious or run to silence or
whatever it's like it shows you that
maybe that thing isn't as sharp as it
was right Little Marco and lion Ted and
whatever else he was using on the other
people I also think something has just
shifted at a at a cultural level where
you know five years ago or whatever it
is now six seven years ago when he was
starting this whole thing he needed to
break through the system in a totally
new way and social media was still a bit
on the new side in terms of pure
politics and all of that stuff and he
needed to do some crazy things to really
get at Hillary and all that and it
worked I think now especially because of
three years of of covid and just what's
going on with the economy and this crazy
Russia Ukraine war that continually is
getting ramped up and now seeing what
China is doing and social credits and
all the stuff we talked about yesterday
I just don't think people want nicknames
anymore I really think at the end of the
day regardless of whether it's DeSantis
or Trump or Rebecca or Nikki or whoever
what people really want more than
anything else not to say that we all
won't get caught up in oh my God that
gotcha moment on the debate stage and he
called this one that one and okay fine
well people want more than anything else
is competency so I thought the Santa's
answer there is right it's like you can
say whatever you want but at the end of
the day I'm a winner look what we've
done here in Florida and Florida clearly
is the freest state in the Union lowest
all-time unemployment our economy is
chuggling along despite everything the
federal government is doing we've got
virtually no crime we've got virtually
no homeless people like it's working
here that's what he has to hang his hat
on and I thought this was a good
question by peers what is the difference
between you and Trump in terms of style
people have been quite kind of scathing
they've said you're house trained Donald
your diet coke to his full Coke right
you've heard all this stuff what are the
differences between you well I know what
I I know him very well I'm having now
spent time with you I can immediately
identify a few differences but what do
you think of the differences well I mean
I think there's a few things I mean
obviously you know the approach to covid
was different I mean you know I would
have fired somebody like fauci uh I
think that he got way too big for his
britches and I think he did a lot of
damage I also think just in terms of my
approach to leadership you know I get
Personnel in the government who have the
agenda of the people and share our
agenda if you bring your own agenda in
you're gone we're just not going to have
that so the way we run the government I
think is no daily drama focus on the big
picture and put points on the board and
I think that that's something that's
very important
solid answer it gets to my point about
competency about the type of people that
you have around you and if you were to
get to the White House again regardless
who the candidate is do you have the
staff that will keep their eye on the
ball that will complete the mission that
won't be leaking left and right is it
all going to be about drama and firing
people and press secretaries that are
there for three days like Anthony
scaramucci or whatever else I think that
is a really Stark difference that that
DeSantis can say hey here's what I've
done and now my roughly five years in
Florida here's the staff that I've
brought along with me that has been
airtight and professional and deals with
the media properly and we don't have
leaks as he said last week we've never
had a leak now by the way it'll be
completely different if they make it to
DC because there is that never-ending
swamp state that exists there it's much
harder to keep things under wraps it's a
whole other challenge so that I grant
him that but I think that's a that's a
really strong point point that if they
get to that debate stage uh it's like
hey Donald who can you staff
your team with at this point who wants
to work for you who haven't you turned
against Etc et cetera there's something
there uh so why is the tension growing
right now right and there's a there's an
obvious reason for it uh what happened
over the last couple days has been sort
of crazy on Friday as you know Trump
with no corroboration uh put on Truth
social that he was going to be arrested
on Tuesday now today is Wednesday so
unless in the last two minutes uh Trump
has been arrested uh it has not happened
yet and it certainly didn't happen on
Tuesday now I can say as I said
yesterday and I will continue to say
without question with no error no no no
nothing
airtight this D.A Alvin Bragg the Soros
funded D.A is absolutely in negligent
negligence of his duty right now we have
been through this before with
impeachment one impeachment two
Mar-A-Lago raid January 6. this is the
machine thrown everything they've got
for purely political purposes because
they do not like Trump and I suspect it
is coordinated in in ways that we do not
know this is not just some you know one
Rogue D.A being like I'm here I'm the
new sheriff in town I'm going to save
the Republic I suspect that there's a
much deeper connections there but
because of that and then the fact that
DeSantis didn't say anything till Monday
now it was Trump announced it Friday
afternoon it was the weekend and then
literally first thing Monday morning
first thing
uh DeSantis talked about it he addressed
it at a press conference it was right
before we started doing the show we
threw the clip in live I thought his
response was absolutely fine he said
look this is a completely ridiculous uh
game that this guy is playing uh he said
that he's a Soros funded D.A he said
I've fired a Soros funded D.A here in
Tampa I'm in a lawsuit about it and I
don't know anything about paying off
porn stars which was kind of funny I
think it was all solid but the bass the
Trump people pissed it to santis okay is
what it is this is what politics is all
about uh DeSantis explained it a bit
more to peers related to his response to
the whole thing
you did a press conference this morning
and you were responding to the reports
rumors of Donald Trump potentially being
indicted
and you gave an interesting response
very sort of supportive of him in a way
by saying yeah you know I think what's
happening there is outrageous it's
political posturing by this deer and so
on in New York and they should be
focused on more important things but you
also repeated twice you didn't have any
knowledge of harsh money being paid to
Pawn Stars
was I right to
feel that there was a slightly
sensorious tone to that that kind of
thing is just not anything you would
ever get involved with well I think it's
there's a lot of speculation about what
the underlying conduct is that is
purported to be it and yeah the reality
is that's just outside my wheelhouse I
mean that's just not something that I
can speak to so uh you know I hope it
doesn't come to where you end up seeing
this going forward I mean look if you
are a very strident prosecutor and this
guy's on the left and you're not
Prosecuting a lot of crimes Manhattan's
gotten less safe you're going to go
after somebody on the other side for
some novel offense uh that just does not
Inspire confidence and people see that
as weaponizing the justice system so so
I think it's fundamentally wrong to do
that and you know I just made it be
known but who you know we'll see maybe
it won't come to that I mean we haven't
seen any
again he's being very clear that this is
politics in action out of this New York
City D.A office it is nothing other than
that and I like the fact that he said
look this is a guy who's not Prosecuting
crime there are all sorts of crazy we I
mean we've shown you them a million
times the New York City stats related to
crime and drugs and homelessness and all
that and the amount of uh it's now
leaking out because people are looking
into this guy Alex Bragg the amount of
uh of uh felonies that he has turned
into misdemeanors people that he has in
jail and then the results of these
people getting back out on the street as
for the thing about Santa's saying you
know he doesn't know what it's like to
pay off a porn star I don't know what
it's like to pay off a porn star any of
you guys know what it's like to pay off
a porn star for sex anyone nobody nobody
in this room does so it's an interesting
point to bring up there's something that
happens when you're paying off a porn
star for sex okay and he's allowed to
joke about it too I mean that's the
thing he joked about it like when I saw
all these Trump people upset that he had
made a joke about it's like Trump jokes
about everybody about their size and
their weight and their behavior and
their age and their and it's just it's
okay anyway I saw a meme uh from an
account called Florida dad on Twitter
that I really thought captured what was
happening over these last couple months
or a couple months these last couple
days here uh it says uh and if you're
familiar with memes you get the the
format that they went with here I can't
believe Rhonda silence hasn't made a
statement about Trump I don't know what
goes into paying hush money to a porn
star to secure silence over some type of
alleged Affair but he is a Soros back to
yay who's going after Trump for
political reasons I can't believe Rhonda
sanctimonious made that statement about
Trump LOL so you get the point the
energy has shifted so that the last four
days or so uh everyone on the Trump side
was angry about DeSantis because of
something that a New York City
Progressive D.A funded by Soros did that
tells you that in some way now the Trump
energy is actually DeSantis energy right
and in 2015 you could sort of you could
look at it this way in some ways because
Trump was The Outsider he was punching
above his weight class right because he
was going after Jeb Bush Ted Cruz Marco
Rubio he was going after the guys that
were in the system so to go after them
with the silly nicknames and whatever it
kind of made sense something is
different now because in 2023 You could
argue it's something like this he's
punching below his weight class first
off DeSantis isn't even a candidate but
DeSantis is the one guy in America the
one politician more than anyone else who
has done it right for the last couple
years so that's why the nicknames are
falling flat or saying you know Florida
was doing great before DeSantis and then
crediting Charlie Chris it's like this
stuff isn't working as I have said many
times and I will continue to say and I
hope I can say it to president Trump to
his face there is 100 percent a case to
be made that Donald Trump is the only
guy who can do this who has put it on
the line before and could do it again
and has the resources to do it and and
the the resentment the well-deserved
resentment of these people maybe he is
the only guy that can drain the swamp
and do the entire thing that's the case
you gotta make but if your case is the
sanctimonious or I'm upset because he
made a joke or some of that stuff it
just isn't going to work but again the
the broad point today
is where really is the energy so much of
politics is just about energy it's about
who people are talking about why they're
talking about them who the media is
going after who they're trying to
destroy and if you think about it really
just think about it clearly the last
couple days who suddenly became the
enemy it was DeSantis more than
the D.A that's where Trump and the Trump
people were focused tells you something
I saw this other tweet from uh from
Florida or this is just a random account
we came across that I thought they were
just making some good points Trump
DeSantis is an establishment uniparty
globalist neocon meatball that Grooms
teenage girls and is probably gay
DeSantis I'm focused on helping
Floridians Maga I will never vote for
DeSantis now after these disloyal
attacks look again I get it guys this is
a little bit of Insider baseball stuff
with politics and I don't want to add to
the destruction of everything that's why
I'm trying to expose some of this stuff
now imagine if all of these guys look
DeSantis can very clearly get on if he's
going to run get on a debate stage and
say this is what I've done this is the
blueprint here's how I will continue to
govern if you if you get me out of uh
you know Florida and take me to DC not
get me out of Florida who would want to
leave Florida to a certain sense but if
I go from Florida to DC here's what I'm
going to do here's the track record
Trump here's what I did last time the
econ economy was way better than we were
at Wars like there's an argument to be
made there Vivek I'm going to be the guy
that understands the economy the most
Etc Nikki here in my foreign policy
chops here's what I did in South
Carolina like there's a way to do all
that stuff so I'm trying to slightly
defang everybody at the moment because
the the hatred that's coming from the
Trump people on DeSantis it's it's just
two minutes ago you guys all loved him
you now you fear him so you hate him but
you all loved him and no everyone just
fundamentally knows what is the what is
the most obvious truth about this he has
been the best governor in the United
States for the past four plus years did
the most on covid his state is
flourishing and most red states are
looking to Florida
as the blueprint to export to to fix
what is wrong with so much of the
country right now and if you want a
little context on uh some of this here's
a post from Trump on Truth social
this is just uh what is this this is
about a month ago and it's a random
picture from a from an anonymous account
with Ron DeSantis when he was I think a
TA or a teacher in college uh with a
couple girls and the implication is that
he was a groomer or a pedophile or
something else and that's what Trump was
doing to disant this a month ago there's
no truth to any of it obviously
um but so for the people that were just
like and to say this didn't defend him
the second that he could of this
uncorroborated thing that still hasn't
happened it's like you know what if you
keep calling someone a pedophile in a
groomer long enough eventually they're
just like ah you know I'm not going to
stick my neck out for that guy and you
kind of can't blame him and the biggest
point on that as I tweeted out last
night
he didn't get arrested what did I tweet
last night I think we've got the tweet
so did Trump get arrested today or not
and uh nah that is the answer it didn't
happen so look it may happen maybe by
the time we close up shop here today
it'll have happened but maybe there was
enough pushback maybe the maybe the
entire machine looked at what was going
on and going man we overplayed our hand
here you can arrest this guy you're
making him more powerful again you know
the more you tighten the grip the more
star systems that'll slip through your
fingers could have been one of those
situations uh anyway Tucker Carlson's
been commenting on this because people
that talk for a living about politics
talk when things happen politically uh
and he was uh where was this was this on
it was on Tucker show right yeah this is
on Tucker show uh we played like 100
Clips before the show today uh this is
on Tucker's show talking about the
possible arrest and the lack of response
from the Biden white house because if
you separate
all of this from what you think Trump
theater didn't do or porn stars and
payoffs and everything else we enter
Banana Republic type stuff when you
start arresting political opponents for
nonsensical things right and you make
everyone think man the whole system is
corrupt and once everyone thinks the
whole system is corrupt that's a system
that is ripe to fail because it only
works as long as we believe that it can
work uh that's what Tucker was
addressing right here
these about when and where Donald Trump
will be arrested fingerprinted and
photographed against a cinderblock wall
for his mug shot
how much of this is true once again we
cannot say here's what we know a Soros
funded prosecutor in New York a man who
ran on the promise to indict Trump seems
to be working hard to indict Trump
indebting him for a crime that no one
even pretends is a crime including the
federal agency that has already
investigated and declared it on a crime
so in Manhattan tomorrow what will
certainly be an overwhelmingly liberal
grand jury will meet and unless
something unexpected happens Democrats
will have taken the unprecedented step
of using a corrupt justice system to
take out the front runner in the
Republican Presidential field in a
presidential race and if that happens
America will never be the same you've
got to hope that for the sake of the
country the Biden White House
which will be running against Trump will
put the country above partisanship and
stop this the mayor Garland at doj will
issue a very public statement saying
that this is wrong which it is and
therefore preserve for grandchildren our
justice system
doesn't seem to be happening
amazing because we we obviously have a
very politicized uh D.A in New York
there's no doubt about it Tucker is
right the guy ran on basically saying he
was going to indict Trump that shouldn't
surprise you you may remember uh
election night when Trump got elected
and Rashida Talib screaming about how
they were going to impeach him just the
night that he got elected and then they
spent obviously four years doing
anything and everything to get rid of
this guy uh what's interesting about
what Tucker said there is I actually
don't know and we should talk to a I
guess probably a constitutional scholar
or a lawyer on this I don't know what
Merrick Garland as the Attorney General
is allowed to do what statement what
sort of statement he's allowed to make
related to a New York City internal
investigation and I don't know that you
would actually want the Attorney General
commenting on an internal investigation
for a city right because I do believe
that City
state federal I don't believe in it this
way I actually technically don't know
what the answer to that is I I suppose
he would be allowed to share his
thoughts on it or something like that
but if it's an ongoing investigation I
don't know all of that but the
overriding point of if you do if you
guys go ahead and do this
on some nonsensical misdemeanor
technicality from years ago that
everyone is way past it is so obvious
that you're doing it just for political
purposes that the fire that you are
going to ignite is going to be it's
going to it potentially could burn
everything down and it could also be the
fuel that sends Trump back into the
White House right if you think about it
the energy now although I'm telling you
that the Trump energy is actually to
Santa's energy people are talking about
Trump again right they are it's just a
simple fact whether you like Trump or
not had they not done this people
wouldn't be talking about him so you
guys you're laying your own trap here uh
anyway Tucker also related to this uh
related this to the D.A himself who is
doing virtually nothing on crime in New
York City which is skyrocketing and
actually not doing nothing he's
reversing some very obvious policies on
how you deal with criminals
so here you have a D.A who treats
violent felonies like they're
misdemeanors even when it gets people
killed who's unleashing criminals on the
population but then spending all of his
time trying to destroy his political
opponents in this case elevating a
misdemeanor charge to the a felony for
the purpose of taking down Trump
if anyone should be looked into here
it's the D.A it's brag at this point
like are you doing things because you
are following the letter of the law
which is what your job is as a D.A
you're supposed to decide what cases get
pushed what people get off what all the
actual technical legal justifications
are for someone being arrested what
we're going to spend time investigating
etc etc are you doing that or are you
doing things for a a much broader
political purpose I think that's fairly
obvious and then Tucker didn't hold back
on what would what the outcome would be
if they go ahead and do this thing
taking out your opponent using the
justice system
if the Democratic party is allowed to do
this allowed to crush the presidential
front runner the main threat to their
power with a bogus criminal case where
does that leave us we're done
because that President will live forever
he's totally right if you start doing
this if we start jailing People based on
politics more than
nonsensical technicalities or what so
you paid off a porn star whatever the
hell it was it doesn't even matter we
all know this is about politics once you
do this once enough of us are like wow
it is all Bs
you need your people to believe in the
system we all have to believe this works
to some extent like we can all go ah
it's crazy and there are wacky
politicians and people always saying
crazy things but enough of us at the
moment believe that the system works so
that it inherently gives the system some
juice
once you basically say okay we're going
to take out a certain set of people
because of course it wouldn't stop with
Trump right I mean and this to Trump's
credit he always says this they're not
going after me they're going after me to
show you that they can come after you
I'm just standing in the way and once
they do that with Trump
do you think they wouldn't do it to
DeSantis do you think they wouldn't do
it to Nikki Haley or literally anyone
else that speaks against the line and it
wouldn't even be political related it
would be pundit related or whatever
whatever it might be that is how you end
up I mean that's what the term Banana
Republic is that it's all just this
endless show and none of it works and
it's asymmetrical and it's based on who
has power and when they have power and
that you will always use that power to
destroy all of your opponents but what
is the mainstream media focused on to me
that's what they should be focused on
regardless of political ideology that's
what they should be focused on that we
cannot enter a situation where we're
going to be arresting Front Runners for
uh presidential primaries right we just
cannot do that but what are they focused
on instead they're focused on the
commentary around the Trump arrest we're
about to show you a clip from the
televised mental institution MSNBC here
is noted racist Joy read and she's upset
that people keep bringing up the George
Soros funded this D.A now before we show
you the clip I just want to be clear
George Soros did fund this D.A he has
also funded DA's in San Francisco Tessa
Bodine who destroyed San Francisco then
got recalled he also funded George
gascon formerly of San Francisco
destroyed that place now destroying Los
Angeles he has also funded DA's in
Philadelphia and in Chicago and in Tampa
and by the way that guy Ron DeSantis
removed him but somehow if you mentioned
that George Soros puts tons of money to
get DA's into these cities to then roll
back laws and then allow criminals out
on the streets and then we know what
happened in all these blue cities
somehow you're being racist yeah
Walder last award to you then on this
the fact that they keep throwing George
soros's name we've talked a lot on the
on in our show meetings is it definitely
feels like a dog whistle that is
dangerous
it absolutely feels like a dog whistle
that's dangerous look most of these
groups of Oath Keepers Boogaloo boys
proud boys they all subscribe to what
you you are all referring to is the
great replacement Theory which is that
idea that the majority of the white
population is is being replaced and this
is why we see these spikes in in racism
these spikes in anti-Semitism is because
they are ascribing to this belief and
it's stoking this this Division I mean
Trump has for multiple years actually
now has called for a Civil War and I
think that's really what he's inferring
when he does that and that's why we're
playing whack-a-mole essentially because
a lot of these online threats
and Republicans are letting him do it
and the Republican party is letting him
do it they stand by and as if that's
okay it's embarrassing it's yeah
you're embarrassing lady whoever you are
these people are so embarrassing the
spikes in racism and the spikes and
attacks on say Jews and Asians in New
York it's funny are they white
supremacists doing these things no it's
virtually all black people
that's just a fact that's not me being
racist that's just telling you what's
happening watch anytime an Asian woman
is just mauled on the street in
Chinatown in New York City or when they
go into Brooklyn and just attack a bunch
of Orthodox Jews it's not a bunch of
white supremacists with maganuses and
flags Like Jesse Smollett would have you
believe in the media would love and
guess what if that was happening you
would know about it because the media
would be going all in on it right it
would be a freaking uh bukaki of uh
information
ah
it was a lot it was a lot the point is
that Alvin brags these DA's they
incentivize all of these racist attacks
because they are soft on crime right
once you say to people ah you know
occasionally you're allowed to just you
know I don't know rape someone in a
vestibule if they're trying to go into
their apartment or just punch a random
person or push them into a Subway
etc etc and instead of call making that
a felony we'll actually downgrade that
to a misdemeanor which this guy has done
on a crazy amount of cases well then bad
guys start doing more bad things it's
sort of what New York City has done with
the Subways once you say uh you know
what if you don't uh swipe your card if
you just jump the Turn Style we're
actually not going to arrest you what
you're doing is twofold on one hand
you're incentivizing criminals right
you're telling people okay just don't
don't pay your way in just break the law
jump the turnstile We're not gonna do
anything and then you're also saying to
all the law-abiding citizens you know
what you're a bunch of suckers you
morons why aren't you jumping the
turnstile old lady you're paying the
money to get in and use the subway and
use public transportation hop That Thing
lady
it's all so stupid but this is what they
have what they have is no matter what
whether it's Trump DeSantis anyone else
what are they going to be they're going
to be anti-black they're going to be a
fascist dictator they're going to be an
anti-semite and anti-gay that is what
they are going to be but don't take my
word for it how about some
mainstream media compilation examples of
exactly what I'm talking about
if Florida Governor Ron DeSantis becomes
president of the United States which he
is clearly aiming for America will
become the land of total government
control over women's bodies black
history gender identity how you can
teach learn rethink even talk it's like
the ultimate gaslighting to basically be
steamrolling fascist policies into the
state and and doing so under the banner
of freedom and rights is terrifying it
feels like a Soviet system or you know
the way the Nazis would build a potemkin
village he really has tried to turn
himself into sort of a local Mussolini
in Florida with the book banding and the
brutal tactics he is somebody that now
has attacked African-American education
he is attacking any type of liberal arts
education this guy just seems like just
sort of a curmudgeonly anti-black and
anti-lgbtq person we have to call this
what this is this is fascism and
authoritarianism that goes even beyond
what Trump has talked about Honda Santa
says uniquely dangerous on cultural
issues and his stride his strive to take
the nation back 50 years
what did I tell you guys six months ago
they are going to call him Hitler with a
calculator right Trump was just orange
Hitler this is the guy who can do it uh
they're coming for women's bodies here
in Florida uh Daphne you're the only
identified woman in this room unless any
of you guys have something to tell me uh
when you got in your car today and made
it all the way here 12 minute drive or
so with your body attacking anyway did
any person with a Florida flag did
anyone nobody came after you and uh guys
did you know any fascism on your way
here or when you were maybe at Trader
Joe's yesterday was there any sort of
incident of fascism or racism did you
Maul a trans person today or attack or
belittle oh actually Brock nodded yes
okay so there was one little minor
incident okay and I'm sure he had his
reasons it's all just insane this is
literally the freest place on Earth it
is the best place to live and flourish
and and be happy and fulfilled and all
of those things if you are watching or
know anyone watching MSNBC you must drug
them and reprogram them you have to take
them to a forest you know they do this
they you know when you have a kid like a
16 year old kid and he's out of control
and he's on the drugs and he's saying
mean words and he's breaking things you
take the kid you put a black hat on
there and you put them in a plane and
you send them off to like the forest
somewhere in Utah or something and then
you have people yell at them and they
have to survive that's what you have to
do to your friends who are watching
MSNBC okay something like that well
Media Matters they're gonna have a field
day with that one Reuben wants the black
bag people and send them to the forest
of Utah
anyway what's really going on here
what's going on here well obviously uh
the DeSantis thing is gaining momentum
that's why Trump's going after him
that's why the lunatics you just have to
look where the the fire is aimed right
where is the fire aimed and that is the
thing that it really matters at the
moment uh and it does seem like the
Santa is gonna run uh here's a tweet
from Florida's voice Governor Ron
DeSantis is reportedly stacking April
travel plans for New Hampshire Ohio and
Michigan uh those are three states that
you might want to travel to if perhaps
you were going to run for president uh
and you know one of the other assets I
would say a bit of a secret weapon that
DeSantis has not not such a secret if
you're here in Florida is that Casey
DeSantis the first lady is is really
doing some incredible stuff you know she
had cancer which she is fully recovered
from and she did an unbelievable job
raising funds after Hurricane Ian and
we've got more from Florida's voice
Casey DeSantis expands hope Florida
program to the private sector and
secures hundreds of thousands in
donations and if you're not sure what
hope Florida is it utilizes hope
Navigators to guide Floridians on an
individualized path to Prosperity
economic self-sufficiency and hope by
focusing on community collaboration
between the private sector faith-based
community non-profits and government
entities to break down traditional
Community silos in an effort to maximize
resources and uncover opportunities
public benefit customers Statewide
Public benefit customers Statewide
children aging out of foster care
pregnant mothers contending with
substance abuse disorders parents and
families who need assistance so we're
trying to do what America was set up to
do we're trying to do some blend of
public private partnership so that
individual people can get help at the
Grassroots ground level and that's what
she's leading on here so look it's
obvious that this thing is going
National whether whether ultimately
whether he announces or not the
blueprint is here and that is what
people need to be focused on of course
the other question is who who would
Trump or DeSantis or whoever it might be
run against and people seem to still
think that Joe Biden is going to run now
at this point the machine is so out of
control the the the Band-Aids on top of
Band-Aids of stupidity here are are so
layered that I think it's possible he's
going to run everyone knows there's
something wrong with him his wife Dr
Jill Biden refuses to have him examined
remember that clip we would never have
him take a cognitive test who do you
think we are
but they keep pretending he's either
running or in charge here's cringe
jean-pierre's uh comment on just that
from yesterday
the president has said many times that
he intends to run I'm not going to go
beyond that that is uh for the president
to decide clearly
all right so I guess he's gonna run as
opposed to falling down the stairs or
falling up the stairs he's better at
falling up the stairs than falling down
the stairs which is a certain skill uh
in and of itself uh but okay let's wrap
the show up today with a sort of
holistic what would make sense going
forward well I think at this point it's
fair to say DeSantis is probably running
I think you know my feelings on what's
going on here in Florida I think you can
see who is taking heat right now and
where the sort of focus is uh so I want
to flash back to a clip that we showed
you about four or five months ago it was
also involving Piers Morgan Jordan
Peterson was on his show in November of
22 telling peers why he thinks DeSantis
would be a better pick than Trump but
perhaps why Trump should still be
running
would you like him to run again would it
be good for America do you think maybe
no I don't think it would be good for
America would it be good for him to run
that's a diff that's a difficult
question because it might be that it
would be good for America to have
whether or not Donald Trump should be
president sorted out in the public
sphere debated intensely and subject to
an election so it might be very
interesting to see him put himself
forward on the Republican ticket if I
had my druthers
um and I say this I hope with due care I
would rather see someone like DeSantis
step forward who shares some of that
forthright
strength let's say that characterizes
Trump at his best but seems to be a more
uh cautious administrator and a less
divisive figure I think that would be
better
choosing your words carefully as you
always do my friend look the point of
all of this guys is every Republican
right now needs to be equipped with the
message they need to be armed with the
idea that we have a much bigger enemy to
fight if all of your fire is focused on
the guy who kept the state open who
fought fauci and the CDC whose state is
flourishing if you're throwing things at
him like he's a pedophile or a groomer
or other nonsensical he's a rhino and a
globalist when you all know it's not
true and we all know it's not true and
it's just sort of it's just nothingness
I'm telling you it there was a reason it
worked last time but sometimes you need
new tricks sometimes you can't just go
back to the old move you know what I
mean like if you were playing basketball
you know and you make a great move you
can maybe make that move on the next
play but on the third play guess what
the defender is going to know what to do
and I think that's what Trump is coming
up against right now we have a major
problem in America that major problem is
that at wokeness and big government and
collectivism and and in essence
communism it's being ushered in through
Democrat socialists who now don't even
say Democrat socialists anymore but the
Socialist movement of government will do
everything for you that is the threat in
America we've got a good crop of
Republicans right now and they have to
make sure look primaries are always
going to be messy that's the thing
there's always going to be hurt feelings
friends are going to turn on each other
all of that stuff but I as I keep saying
Trump has just got to level up if he
really wants this thing make the case
for Trump but if it's just going to be
low blow low low blow and here's a
picture of him with some girls a long
time ago it ain't gonna work and it
degrades you I really I really do
believe that uh Jordan in February of 22
so this is a little over a year ago
Jordan Peterson was on the Patrick Bet
David podcast talking not about
political racehorse politics DeSantis
Trump and all that but talking about how
actually there is a new message to be
heard from young people right now that
conservatives for the first I'm in a
long time actually have a message to get
across and that if they do that
effectively that things can get much
better and it can happen pretty quickly
I really love this answer take a look
a better story tell a better story if
you want to get reelected no no no no no
no no no no no
the way to re-election is through a
better story but that's not the reason
to tell it
the reason to tell it is because you
believe it and there for the first time
in my life really I believe this to be
the case conservatives really have
something to sell to young people
and they have the they can sell the
meaning of responsibility
because young people are bereft of
meaning
and most people find meaning and
responsibility
and and when the right talks about
responsibility they kind of do it in
that finger wagging way that makes
conservatives unpopular among young
people you should be responsible it's
like yeah you should why
well
because your life is chaotic and
meaningless and you're stuck in this
juvenile surreality
and it's really painful for you and
you're anxious and aimless and goalless
and then you look at people who have a
life because maybe you could have a life
and you think well what does that life
consist of it's like well you have a
committed intimate relationship there's
one you have friends that you're honest
with and and playful with so you have a
group of friends you have a job or a
career you know you you learn how to use
your life your time outside of work in a
productive engaging way you regulate
your susceptibility to
the multitude of hedonistic temptations
that are in front of you you
pay some attention to your mental and
physical health you make a goal some
goals for the future that are concrete
interesting what what Jordan's
describing right there which we all know
is kind of right like if you take some
responsibility for yourself maybe you'll
find someone that you can fall in love
with and build a family maybe you'll
find friends and co-workers that you
respect and like maybe you'll control
some of your crazier impulses that that
is the conservative message that young
people need I mean why is it that the
the progressive young people who are now
confused about their gender and are
suddenly selling that you should be fat
and that you shouldn't know what the
difference between boys and girls are
and you should judge people based on the
color of your skin why are they all
miserable and screaming and unproductive
and then there's this other set of
people and I meet them at all the events
that I do that are young people who are
seriously impressive because they're
putting the pieces together that's the
message that conservatives should have
and then to link that to everything else
that we've talked about today the
question I suppose for the rest of us
whether whether you're a young person
just doing the beginnings of that or if
you're someone in in middle age doing
that or you're someone uh in in your
elderly years or older years trying to
conserve those good things who is the
best person to Steward a country that
can lead us to that and that is the
decision that we will all have to make
from where I sit right now obviously I
think Ron DeSantis what he has done in
the level of confidence and and the
Florida focused Freedom initiative is
obviously the best way to go forward on
that but again there is a case to be
made for Trump and if this all ends with
DeSantis remaining governor of Florida
and Trump being president I will be
freaking thrilled that might be the that
might be the best situation especially
uh for everyone in this room as
Floridians it really might be but the
question is if you believe in personal
responsibility and all the things Jordan
just laid out there who can help seed
that who can help seed so that so the
world
will allow you to do all of those things
do you want it to be someone that is
hyper competent and and not playing all
the games and not getting lost in all
the craziness or do you want sort of
mutually assured destruction and all of
all of that maybe there's a reason for
that that's what you have to think about
for yourself uh and I want to show you
one other clip of Jordan this is also
with uh Patrick David talking about how
to market the message because it's not
just that telling people you know he's
saying in the old days conservatives
would Wag the finger you kids better
grow up and be more like us because look
at us we wear our shirts tucked in and
you like the rock and roll okay that's
not how you get people across the Finish
Line you can start doing it uh in all
sorts of ways that Jordan obviously is
that there is a there is a power to life
if you start taking care of yourself
appropriately but really what we have to
do and I think this is quite simple is
contrast it what the left contrasted
with what the left is selling because
they're selling a bill of goods that is
faulty it's shiny but it's faulty as
hell Jordan talked about that
conservatives can make that case no
bloody left isn't making that case it's
like for them responsibility is pretty
much equivalent to totalitarian
patriarchal oppression
the conservatives could just take that
say no no our institutions they're
pretty solid
maybe if you don't like what's happening
on the political front you join
a group a church uh the Elks the rotary
some Civic organization get in there and
do your part why not because you should
even though you should but because
well why not meet some people who are
like-minded and have a social group
wouldn't that be something if we all did
that and I can tell you as a as a new
Floridian every Sunday we go to the
farmers market here and I meet people I
meet the local vendors everybody kind of
knows me I chat with everybody I drop
I'll buy honey from the local guy who's
selling honey and uh you know our
vegetables from the local guys selling
vegetables and then you start knowing
people and you start becoming less
cynical about things and you realize boy
I'm doing all right I can help this guy
do all right and then our community is
kind of feeling pretty good right and
what does that all lead to it leads to a
flourishing uh community at the micro
level City above that state above that
and then maybe we can export that so
that we'd have a flourishing country
once again and we could get back to the
United States that might be a little
Pollyanna at this point maybe it is just
too screwy in some of those blue States
but there's a chance and we do have
something better to sell and to tie this
all together the question is will we
sell that in aspirational message or
will we just go down the path of I want
power so I will do everything I can to
destroy everybody else including the
people who have done it the best
Trump has to make that decision for
himself and again I I mean this with
respect and I will gladly sit down and
talk to him about it that's the decision
he has to make will I go scorched Earth
to attain power again I I feel that I
was unjustly uh not voted in for a
second term or however he wants to
phrase that and I'm so pissed about it
and I think I'm the only one that can do
this that I will destroy the guy who's
the governor of the state I live in who
has done absolutely everything right in
the in the Quest for that power and then
we all have to decide how we want to
play Within that game
this was a very mature show today I
limited the bukaki reference was a
little gratuitous but I think besides
that
sorry sorry we're having Shake Shack for
lunch that's pretty good so it's like
it's a wash it's a wash
anyway uh
Phoenix is grading me on the Fly he
would have given this the rare 10 today
it was a serious show it was sobering
wasn't the funniest show we've ever done
but it was a solid show I think everyone
could agree on that I've been docked
point one point for the
reference they're giving me a nine nine
but we leave it up to you guys uh I'll
chat with the rest of you guys in the
locals post game show in just a moment
if you want to join us
reubenport.locals.com and we've got the
iOS app and the Android app if you want
to download that and play along with us
uh part one of my interview with Nikki
Haley is up on YouTube and Rumble right
now full things up ad free at locals uh
we leave you with more of the machine
doing it with Democrats and I'll see
everybody in about 40 seconds ciao
how quickly how quickly would I
that sends an ice cream oh
[Music]